what's wrong with feeling like you
deserve something the ego flares you
believe you deserve it which means you
can't be grateful for it you can't be
both grateful and have an ego which is
why I think gratitude's been so
difficult for me in my life it's been
like of course this happened I would
expect this to happen which also removes
a lot of the Joy from anything and so
it's been something that I've worked a
lot on and I don't think that there's a
solution to it I think it's just like
the consistent chiseling away you know
layer by layer of it and trying to
remind myself that like you know my
worldview is like when I die nothing
happens and I am not as significant as I
like to pretend to be this is a quote
from Naval who quoted somebody else
bizarre as a contract we make with
ourselves to be unhappy until we get
what we want if your expectation is zero
of reality everything above zero is
positive